[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue tout
de suite le sommaire de cette émission
on va parler de ce qui se passe à nantes
nantes deux jours après les violences
lors d'un contrôle qui a commencé avec
les contrôles de police qui a bouté à la
mort d'un jeune homme atteint par un tir
de crs au cou le premier ministre était
sur place ce matin il promet la
transparence sur l' enquête en cours
nous verrons ce que vous en pensez
on parlera aussi des manuels macron qui
semble décroché cette fois dans les
sondages nous découvrirons les chiffres
dans un instant ils sont mauvais donc
pour l'exécutif
et en plus le cafouillage sur les
réformes fait très mauvais effet dernier
cafouillage en date que le plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté
reportée à cause du mondial de foot la
bourde risque de faire mal au président
des riches
on parle beaucoup de la hongrie ces
derniers temps notamment à cause de la
crise des migrants
cette fois c'est l'ambassadeur de france
en hongrie qui fait parler de lui sa
défense de la politique du premier
ministre viktor orban le attiré les
foudres du quai d'orsay eric fournier
c'est son nom at-il raison at il tort
nous en débattrons enfin nous nous
poserons cette question quasi
existentielle
êtes vous plutôt foot ou plutôt tour de
france vous y réfléchissez vous
intervenez chers internautes point de
vue c'est fait pour cela à nos invités
on donne 45 minutes pour se décider donc
foot au cyclisme on en parlera en fin
d'émission et vous pouvez encore
réfléchir un peu caroline michel merci
de michel aguer merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir
vous êtes l'une des responsables du
service enquêtes de l'ops up ce qui fait
sa couverture cette semaine sur une
question existentielle des questions
existentielles la nouvelle formule du
bonheur je n'ai méditer cuisiner et
embrasser les arbres jean louis
bourlanges là je vous demanderai votre
recette du bonheur ce que vous êtes
plutôt cuisine méditation écouter
méditation après cuisine ça s'appelle le
chef vous êtes député des hauts-de-seine
élu il ya un an sous l'étiquette modem
centriste vous vous retrouvez dans la
politique d' emmanuel macron trouve
certainement à l'inspiration globale de
la politique d' emmanuel macron bien
qu'effectivement au jour le jour on l'a
parfois des difficultés à suivre telle
ou telle évolution telle ou telle prise
de position mais sur les orientations
fondamentales et notamment celles qui
font le plus problème par exemple la
suppression isf par exemple ses
engagements européens
je reste la question approuvez bonjour
vous êtes politologue universités à vous
enseigner la théorie politique à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et vous avez publié c'était
aux éditions le mieux l'année dernière
la gauche jean bie chronique d'une
malédiction politique et bonjour vincent
trémolet de villers vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du figaro vous
cette conversation française notre
dernier livre paru aux éditions du cerf
en 2016 avec deux ans des entretiens et
laurent b et on va aussi faire un peu de
promotion pour le figaro magazine et sa
couverture cette semaine c'est migrants
ce que l'on vous cache alors d'abord
nantais cette affaire d'un jeune homme
donc mortellement touché par un tir d'un
crs lors d'un contrôle d'identité c'est
tous les ingrédients d'un dossier ultra
sensible avec deux versions qui
s'affrontent d'un côté celle des jeunes
qui parlent tout de suite de bavure de
l'autre celle de policiers des syndicats
politiques parlent de légitime défense
la bâche la balle a donc touché la
victime au cou laquelle victime était
sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt pour
vol en bande organisée une marche
blanche commence à nantes dans moins
d'une heure et quant au policier auteur
du tir il vient d'être placé en garde à
vue en aplat parler tout ça le premier
ministre était donc ce matin à nantes
on l'écouterait dans le même temps
exprimer mon soutien le cru ferme pour
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre des
policiers
ceux qui travaillent au sein des
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
les pompiers des médecins qui sont
intervenus
dans la nuit d'hier et dans la nuit
d'avant-hier dans des conditions parfois
très difficiles et donc il parle de
soutien on écoute également laurent
wauquiez pour les républicains qui lui
parle de présomption d'innocence com -
on laisse les enquêtes se dérouler et
que d'abord il ya une présomption qui
une présomption de défense de nos forces
de l'ordre mois entre d'un côté un
malfaiteur poursuivi pour trafic de
stupéfiants et de l'autre côté des
forces de police je demande que la
présomption d'innocence elle soit du
côté des forces de l'ordre jean louis
bourlanges laurent wauquiez a raison de
parler de présomption d'innocence pour
les forces de l'ordre je crois qu'il n'y
a pas de présomption d'innocence pour
les forces de l'ordre c'est une
expression qui me paraît tout à fait
absurde
il doit il ya une autre il ya une
enquête judiciaire qui doit être mené
qui est menée je crois dans un climat de
grande impartialité et c'est tout il
n'ya pas de la présomption d'innocence
elle est acquise à tout le monde et
c'est pas parce que ce policier
semble-t-il est mise en garde à vue que
sa présomption d'innocence est mise en
cause c'est pas c'est pas ça le problème
simplement effectivement face à un fait
divers absolument tragique qui met en
cause le leu leu à la fois une
communauté qui est totalement délabrée
une vie une vie romaine terrible et
d'autre part des forces de l'ordre ou
des pompiers qui sont harcelés de tous
côtés
il est facile à un homme politique de
dire voilà je suis du côté des forces de
l'ordre voilà le message politique que
je vais passer
moi je crois qu'il faut faire preuve de
beaucoup de retenue dans cette affaire
veillez à ce que la justice fasse son
travail en toute impartialité
j'ai écouté le procureur je trouve
qu'ils parlent très bien des choses et
je crois qu'il faut vraiment raison
garder et la présomption d'innocence
c'est un principe il est acquis
laurent bouvet sur cette affaire
présomption d'innocence pour que je
partage tout à fait ce qui vient d'être
dit par jean louis bourlanges la mort
d'un jeune homme est toujours
un drame c'est la famille qui suivit ça
même si ce jeune homme par ailleurs
étaient délinquants enfin bon les choses
sont ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
et de la même manière le policier n'a
pas n'a certainement pas donner la mort
enfin l' enquête le dira je ne présume
en rien une enquête mais la police ne
tue pas avec intention ou pour se part
par une arme spéciale les jeunes quand
il y a effectivement il ya de temps en
temps des des actes de ce type d'aidé
des faits de ce type c'est toujours dans
des circonstances particulières c'est
souvent de la part des policiers une
manière aussi de se défendre ils sont
souvent aussi attaqué voilà et donc il y
à des circonstances que l'enquêté
établira ce qu'on peut simplement dire
c'est qu'effectivement sur les réactions
politiques
il y a eu des tentatives de manipulation
un peu de tous les côtés mais moi j'ai
entendu certains élus j'ai vu un
communiqué notamment de de benoît hamon
pour faire pendant un peu à ce que vous
montriez de laurent wauquiez
benoît hamon lui se place tout de suite
immédiatement du côté de la victime du
jeune qui a été tué sans aucune
considération pour les forces de l'ordre
la difficulté de la situation du métier
etc
je crois qu'il faut effectivement raison
garder il faut laisser la justice faire
son travail
établir les faits tels qu'ils se sont
déroulés avec l'ensemble des ténors inga
iii éventuellement dire quelque chose
car lille michel le premier ministre
c'est vrai il a quand même
essentiellement soutenu les forces de
l'ordre il n'a pas en tout cas dans les
déclarations qu'on a on entendu il n'a
pas fait
un mot pour la victime amont pour les
forces de l'ordre c'est une nouvelle
façon de présenter les choses
ce qui me frappe dans cette histoire
c'est que la même réaction vient à
chaque fois sur les mêmes sujets je
m'explique les quartiers et réagissent à
chaque fois de la même façon à ce genre
de faits qui sont perçues par eux comme
des bavures policières et pourquoi réagi
style comme ça parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment très ancrée d'une impunité et
d'un deux poids deux mesures ce qui va
dans leur sens c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
n'existe pas de statistiques sur ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des bavures
ça n'est pas ça n'était pas comptabilisé
ça n'était pas cet état bout
c'était totalement tabou en septembre
2010 est elle à vigoureux chez nous avec
la une enquête sur ce sujet tabou et en
travaillant sur un certain nombre de
statistiques en les comptabilisant avait
récolté l'existence de 90 morts 94 morts
par les forces de l'ordre en disant et
sur 55 dossiers dont elle avait pu
suivre le cours il y avait seulement
trois condamnations avec aucune ferme
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur ce
genre de sujet tôt qu on regarde qu'on
sortira pas de la posture de qui a
raison qui a tort légitime défense quand
on ne regardera pas les choses et qu'on
essaiera pas d'être transparents là
dessus on aura toujours ce type de
réaction il ya eu un petit progrès en
juin dernier parce que la patronne de
l'igpn est quelqu'un de très sensée
quand elle est arrivée elle a été
surprise que ces statistiques existent
aux états unis et pas en france et elle
a publié pour la première fois en juin
des statistiques sur des interventions
policières violente ça ne veut pas dire
des bavures bien entendu mais je pense
que il ne faut pas faire oh là là à
chaque fois ça prend feu une fois le
fond du truc pour en revenir à la
gestion par le gouvernement depuis deux
jours vincent très mal et c'est le
gouvernement comme les bbc les choses ne
le dit pas il sait les choses parce que
les informations du remonte mais il ne
lira pas à chaque fois comme vous
zié qui lie à un événement comme ça il
ya la même histoire pourquoi parce qu'il
ya la récupération d'une tragédie la
mort d'un homme par des gens qui
tiennent un territoire et qui veulent
rappeler à ceux qui représentent l'ordre
républicain qu'ils ne sont pas les
bienvenus dans ce territoire ça
s'appelle des zones de non droit où des
zones d'un autre droit c'est à dire le
droit de la délinquance le droit de ce
que vous voulez et le le
l'arrière-plan de toute cette histoire
au delà de la sphère de ce jeune homme
et du policier c'est ça qui se joue
c'est rappeler alors s'il a une tragédie
donc ça le découpe mais ça arrive tous
les jours on jette des blocs de
parpaings sur les pompiers la police ne
peut pas rentrer il ya des endroits où
les médecins ne peuvent pas rentrer et
pourquoi pour dire ici vous ne rentrez
pas c'est nous qui faisons la loi quand
bien même ce serait une bavure qu'est ce
qui légitime parce qu'il ya une belle du
jour derrière le fait de brûler des
bibliothèques
ben quoi en quoi qu'est ce qui autorise
ça il n'y a pas de colère sociale qui
autorise à brûler une bibliothèque dans
un accident dans un état qui fit pas un
autre moyen d'expression laissez pas
vous allez peut-être non mais votre
votre bienveillance et et vous honore
mais va bien mais moi je trouve que j'ai
travaillé sur ce qu on appelle les zones
de non droit pendant un an il ya 15 ans
et que c'est une technique
c'est une technique c'est à dire
utiliser la charge émotionnelle d'une
victime pour rappeler que l'on tient un
territoire et sadia et on est
complètement par centaines en france où
il est très difficile de pouvoir entrer
et donc
je pense qu'au gouvernement le sait
parce qu'ils sont mieux renseigné que
nous tous ici et qui savent que on joue
avec le feu et donc il ya une très
grande prudence aussi dans la gestion de
ce dossier on l'a vu à nantes depuis
deux jours il ya des pas mal de
reportages où les habitants du quartier
en question se disent ces violences ça
va pas les commerces saccagés les
voitures incendiées est-ce que ça serait
aussi aux habitants de prendre un peu
les choses un accord c'est très
difficile parce que ça veut dire que ça
pourrait déboucher sur des formes de
milices privées de faire la loi soit
même et c'est ce qui est tout à fait
juste dans ce que disait centre est
menée à l'instant c'est qu'il y à un
certain nombre de cités qui du fait de
la manière dont elles ont été
construites sans routes d'accès qui les
traversent et c'est pour des raisons
urbanistiques et puis pour des raisons
d' abandon par les élus locaux
le fait qu'il y ait un certain nombre de
services publics qui n'est plus qu'ils
n'ont pas été suivies et c'est en
général tout ce qui reste c'est l'école
qui est la seule le seul service public
encore présent deviennent des
effectivement des zones sans aucune
intervention de la puissance publique et
avec par exemple des systèmes de couvre
feu fait par les gens qui tiennent les
cités sur le trafic etc vous pouvez pas
effectivement appelé un médecin si votre
enfant est malade donc il ya une
exacerbation des tensions très fortes
il y a aussi une forme de dison de
mutisme général qui est dû au fait que
ces sites et génère aussi par l'économie
parallèle des revenus et qu'il y a
beaucoup de
amis qui de gens qui vivent et c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est à dire qui c'est aussi une manière
de vivre pour beaucoup donc d'un côté
des gens regrettent l'absence de
services publics le fait qu'ils aient
des dégradations le fait que
effectivement la vie soit mise en coupe
réglée notamment à partir d'une certaine
heure on coupe l'électricité public dans
certaines ne citer etc il ya des formes
de couvre feu et puis en même temps ils
ont aussi des bénéfices lemay entre
guillemets il faut pas faire de la
provocation inutile là dessus mais des
bénéfices d'une série de paix sociale et
quand il y à un événement qui vient
perturber et ce sont les forces de
l'ordre le perturbateur en l'occurrence
de la tranquillité entre guillemets là
aussi public de c2c lieu effectivement
il y a immédiatement une mise sous
tension et des réactions systématique
comme on en voit on notera que le
policier en cause ici d'un crs 1 ce
n'est pas un policier local ce n'est pas
un policier de la bac par exemple où
évidemment du commissariat local et
c'est donc ce sont aussi des éléments
sur la manière dont on gère la sécurité
publique depuis des années qu'il faut
avoir en tête
à la question que vous posez sur twitter
avez vous l'impression que le
gouvernement gère bien les émeutes à
nantes et bien vous êtes pour le moment
77% à répondre que non
avec ces réactions que je vous livre
jean michel qui nous dit quand
allons-nous nous occuper des banlieues
et des zones de non droit pour reprendre
ce que vous disiez vincent clerc je suis
militaire et je ne tire pas sur les gens
sur quelqu'un qui s'enfuit c'est
interdit ce n'est pas de la légitime
défense donc la claire entre dans le
débat sur l' enquête elle même et loïc
la seule solution c'est d'envoyer leur
jeu l'a très bien dit il ya deux niveaux
dans cette histoire il ya un niveau
judiciaire où il y aura une enquête qui
a fait quoi mais le fait qu'il y ait la
possibilité ou non d'une erreur de la
police ne légitime en rien et n'explique
en rien je pense qu'il faut trouver
l'explication de ces violences ailleurs
elles prennent elles ont là un prétexte
mais c'est un élément déclencheur mais
elles viennent de beaucoup plus loin et
elle pourrait naître un peu partout dans
d'autres cités en france
si vous voulez le lie à certains
endroits où la police n'intervient pas
pour des faits mineurs parce qu'elle
sait qu'une intervention peut amener à
des situations extrêmes et que les
situations extrêmes pourrait on est déjà
là il ya eu un potager puisque le fait
sont passés à nantes et à
garges-lès-gonesse ville dont est
originaire le jeune la jeune victime il
ya la tentation fondamentale est qui et
qui est une tentation que nous avons
tous en réalité c'est de ne pas
intervenir c'était un peu le camp
sarkozy a dit on arrête la police de
proximité et tous ces gens qui jouent au
football avec les délinquants c'est de
dire écoutez ce sont des gens impossible
la racaille comme disait sarkozy on les
laisse là et on se tient à l'extérieur
de tout ça et on fait des ghettos c'est
une tentation très très spontané parce
que on se tire d'affaires où ils font
leurs affaires plus ou moins délinquants
de criminels des bénéfices souvent
importants etc et on ne regarde pas et
l'attitude courageuse c'est aussi
l'attitude la plus risquée évidemment ça
consiste à dire on va réduire ces zones
de non droit ça implique un
investissement mais bon lorsque le plan
borloo et côté non mais le plan borloo
c'est une autre affaire là c'est une
doctrine de sécurité ont fait énormément
de choses sur la politique de la ville
moi je crois que le plan borloo il
ils étaient ils auraient dû être
accueillies de façon beaucoup plus
positive par le président de la
république qui l'avait commandé mais je
veux dire c'était pas en quelques
semaines que les dispositions du plan
borloo qui coûté extrêmement cher etc
auraient changé les choses le vrai
problème c'est de savoir si on investit
massivement sur la réduction de ces
zones de non droit et ça veut dire
chaque fois et
voilà c'est très clair prendre des
risques il faut il faut assumer ces
risques à mon avis mais c'est prendre
des risques on perturbe une fourmilière
qui tourne très bien sans 100 personnes
dans l'illégalité la plus complète et on
chance c'est une reconquête de tous
côtés policière civile sociale
c'est un travail énorme et extrêmement
coûteux et ça implique certainement des
attitudes qui sont exactement aux
antipodes de ce que par exemple extrême
droite demande qui dit faux faut pas
s'en occuper
au contraire il faut mettre énormément
d'argent là-dedans énormément de courage
c'est pas du tout du tout évident et je
trouve que la droite la gauche le centre
l'opposition la majorité
quand on voit la façon dont nous avons
tous échoué au cours des trente
dernières années
on devrait être extrêmement solidaire et
modeste dans cette approche parce que un
véritablement personne n'a quoi se
vanter pragmatisme ne nuirait pas quand
michel navire je suis surprise de là de
la manière dont vous tournez les débats
avec vincent qui parle de près de
bienveillance de ma part quand je viens
dire quelque chose de simple d'abord un
sortir des postures dans ce que vous
dites le gouvernement gère bien on gère
pas bien c'est juste de la posture il
vient là pour dire je défends les forces
de l'ordre
ok super aucune solution après je ce que
je disais ça n'était pas de la
bienveillance c'est d'abord un
identifiant le malaise d'abord sur ce
point là est ce que ces quartiers-là ont
raison ou pas de sentir qu'il y à une
injustice
ça n'est que l'étincelle mais parlons
déjà d'étincelles parce que cette
attaque celle là elle est valable pour
l'ensemble du problème c'est à dire que
cet embrasement
il est lié à ce sentiment d'injustice de
déclassement de ghettoïsation mais ça
part comme vous le disiez ce c'est sur
tous les sujets là c'est sur la bavure
policière
ce sera sur l'intégration sociale sur
l'intégration sur le marché du travail
et tant qu'on ne sort pas de la posture
du rapport de force
et de dire ok on prend le problème de
façon arrête de juger on a deux c'est
dresser l'un en face de l'autre et ça
passe par le fait de reconnaître les
violences policières
salem l'un de la bienveillance explore
ce que sa perte et ol et c'est pas mal
de marques aussi évident de la ferté
aulas on était vraiment dans un schéma
de dont parlait laurent bouvet au dessus
j'ai deux mois mon c'est à dire que le
président de la république c'est quand
même déplacé pour aller voir teocalli
nationale sur son lit et l'art on était
dans la posture et dans l'utilisation
peut-être même électoral à sa médiation
au symbolique mais je voudrais me
répondre sur vous avez employé une
formule qui qui qui qui traverse à
l'inconscient collectif français qui est
celle de deux poids deux mesures vous la
tribu et boeing mais vous savez que vous
très bien que le reste du pays c'est à
dire les gens qui ne brûlent pas de
voiture qui travaille qu'on peut être
leurs enfants agressés on se comprend on
se dit attendez là moi j'applique la loi
et puis pour y aller dans les arguments
bien bien bas
je roule à 90 km/heure peut faire
arrêter et à côté qui se passe ça bon et
donc se voir et se doit demeurer par
exemple il existe très très profondément
dans ce qu'on appelle la majorité
silencieuse de ceux qui ne pratiquent
pas ce genre de d'actes et une moi je ne
trouve pas je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
légitimer par une quelconque on en mai
par une quelconque relégation sociale
qui serait à discuter parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de travaux qui sortent montrant
que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça qui est un choix de
ghettoïsation chez certains qui rien ne
justifie que l'on arrive à de telles
extrémités
si la loi doivent être combattus c'est
tout il ya effectivement il n'ya pas de
poids de mieux et les gens qui
respectent la loi les gens qui la
respectent pas mais le problème global
est d'une autre nature c'est un problème
social et politique mais là il quand on
est en face de délinquants il faut
sanctionner sinon ça n'a pas de sens
quelques réactions encore jean martin
qui ne s'interroge l'état a peur de
faire le ménage peur de la guerre civile
se demande-t-il et citoyen c'est le
pseudonyme de notre internaute le
gouvernement récolte les fruits de son
ninacs
face à la chienlit de ses banlieues qui
l'attend ménages et enfin lolo le sait
pas le gouvernement répond vincent très
molle et plus au gouvernement avant suis
le gars 30 ans d'inaction disait jean
lannes pour l'orge et lolo le ministre
de l'intérieur ne défend pas ses hommes
c'est scandaleux gérard collomb hier à
ma dans mon souvenir a fait une
déclaration pour dire qu'il était le
soutenez les forces de l'ordre en tout
cas dans leur relation de maintien de
l'ordre
on passe à notre deuxième thème si vous
voulez bien c'est celui de d'emmanuel
macron des réformes la journée celle là
commence à faire beaucoup le report du
plan contre la pauvreté à la rentrée
comme celui sur l'hôpital donc après
l'ajournement d'autres projets comme
celui sur l'organisation de l'islam sur
les lois bioéthiques les réformes c'est
donc pour plus tard en tout cas celle là
mais la baisse de la popularité du
président s'est maintenant les derniers
sondages vont tous dans le même sens on
va en parler tout de suite mais avant
écoutons 7 agnès buzyn mise de la santé
elle justifie avec un peu de légèreté ou
d'improvisation le report de cette
réforme on la regarde c'était hier matin
sur lci
en théorie la semaine prochaine ça ça
dépend peut-être aussi des matches de
l'équipe de france parce qu'il fallait
de la france disponibilité et donc
normalement ce plan devrait être
présenté autour du 10 juillet mais nous
verrons si l'équipe de france est en
demi finale ou pas l'on pouvait vous
secoue la tête et vous avez l'air de
deux fois je suis désolé moi je j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour agnès buzyn
et travail de médecin qu'elle a fait et
c'est quelqu'un de tout à fait
respectable mais la politiquement elle
fait une erreur
enfin c'est un manque de sens politique
si vous voulez parce qu'on ne peut pas
sur un sujet aussi important sur un plan
qui a été annoncé dire simplement
écouter oui il ya les matchs de l'équipe
de france etc
il faut même si peu importe la véritable
raison et je ne pense pas que ça soit
simplement les matchs de l'équipe de
france je transmets on est au delà mais
simplement politiquement en termes de
professionnalisme politique il faut
argumenter autrement on ne peut pas dire
comme le dit agnès buzyn bah oui moi ça
s'arrête le match est ce que le
président sera là ou pas bon et puis on
verra où comme je les ai entendues aussi
d'un député de la république en marche
oui oh mais en septembre on sera encore
en est alité donc le plan c'est bien un
plan présenté dans l'été fasse ce genre
d'art gré si c'est ça va pas du tout si
ici les gants éléments de langage il
doit ya voir j'ai cru comprendre que
c'étaient l'alpha et l'oméga maintenant
de la communication politique
il faut qu'il soit bien préparée bien
argumentée et à ce moment là a expliqué
que l'exécutif prend quelques mois de
plus pour élaborer un plan qui va
beaucoup plus loin beaucoup plus
approfondie en concertation avec des
acteurs qu'on prend le temps de mettre
en place quelque chose de sérieux voyez
un jeu là je suis moi et termes de coûts
c'est une femme qui a beaucoup d'humour
donc je suis très sensible à son humour
je crois effectivement que là c'était
pas du tout le bon registre d'une façon
générale je pense que les ministres les
ministres qui sont issus de la société
civile ont de grandes qualités ils sont
compétents il renouvelle profondément
par rapport à au personnel politique
traditionnel mais je trouve qu'il leur
manque quelque chose
globalement ce que les romains
appelaient la gravité de la gravité sire
que le la parole publique est une parole
qui a une solennité une objectivité un
poids un engagement qui va bien au delà
des personnes qui la porte
qui c'est celle du gouvernement c'est
celle de l'état et là je trouve que mais
c'est pas seulement le gouvernement
d'ailleurs actuellement la société
politique française mélange complètement
le registre de la communication de des
numéros médiatique
2 de la parole publique là nous sommes
effectivement sur la santé sont la
pauvreté son dos sur les migrations sur
d'autres réformes nous sommes en phase
de très grands enjeux très lourd qui
demande des réformes bien préparé et
souvent elles ne sont pas assez préparée
et qui demande à être effectivement mise
en scène mais pas au sens théâtral du
coton communication du terme et
présenter au peuple français dans toute
implication et là il ya une petite
désert une légère désinvolture dont
agnès buzyn n'a pas hélas le monopole
cavalli michel aguer on va voir quelques
chiffres sur les sondages
notamment celui ci c'est le baromètre du
figaro
kantar sofres et qui est assez éclairant
puisque le président de la république
perd 6 points en un mois c'est ça pour
être à plus de 2 français sur 3 près de
deux français sur trois qui ne lui font
pas confiance on se dit mais pourtant
des réformes
il en fait que sanctionne les français
plusieurs choses qu'il faut peut-être
voir en fonction des catégories ya
d'abord les électeurs de gauche qui
réalise au bout d'un an qu'ils ont élu
un président de droite et libérale le en
même temps la partie sociale sécurité
filets de protection est repoussée aux
calendes grecques c'est le pompon plan
pauvreté mais ce n'est pas seulement la
réforme de l'assurance chômage etc dont
on attendait beaucoup ça n'est pas l' or
je dirais que la parti libéral a été
fait avec une très grande célérité et
une très grande fermeté
donc le en même temps n'est pas là on a
la même chambre a logiquement il y à une
partie de sa et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'on est rentré dans une phase
d'hésitation ou qui fait que la personne
présidentielle dans le mode de
fonctionnement de ce gouvernement là la
personne président il n'a pas de fusible
emmanuel macron et donc la personne
présidentielle attire tous les regards
et dans cette séquence là ce que je
trouve très angoissant pour les
électeurs c'est que agnès buzyn en creux
il dit écoutez le président de la
république
il a dit qu'il serait en russie voir les
matches donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
il ne se passe plus rien pendant quinze
jours et comme vous avez un président
qui a eu extrêmement bien su communiquer
faire du storytelling de de très haute
volée jusqu'à présent mais au bout d'un
moment le storytelling on touche au
coeur de ce que sont les gens et les
gens ont l'impression à tort ou à raison
de découvrir un président qui ne s'est
pas tout surtout contrairement à ce qui
nous a dit et qui est un peu en manque
d'affecter ce qu'on voit aussi dans
cette séquence autres et autres chiffres
vincent sur lequel de réagir c'est celui
que de notre sondage doxa de consulting
qui paraît lui demain dans le figaro et
l'inde est l'une des applications c'est
que maintenant la politique du
gouvernement et des manuels maquereau a
jugé inefficace par 65% des sondés c'est
un chiffre assez éclairant oui ça montre
qu'il est un père aimant les il a quitté
la stratosphère il a rejoint
l'atmosphère est jusqu'ici sans n'était
pas si mal sorti comparé à ses deux
prédécesseurs mais maintenant il
bénéficie plus de l'effet de contraste
avec françois hollande je pense que
c'est quand même ça le premier élément
qui explique cette baisse il ya un effet
de contraste avec lui même et avec
lui-même et le début de son mandat et le
début de ce mandat était un début très
prometteur et à mon avis trop
prometteurs dans le report des
différentes réformes de long dont on
parle
certaines ne sont pas indispensables par
exemple la réforme de l'islam l'islam de
france est quelque chose de très grave
de très compliqué et ça n'est pas grave
de ne pas le faire pendant la première
année du mandat
le problème c'est qu emmanuel macron a
tout promis a dit on va faire ça au pas
de charge et maintenant pourquoi il ne
les fait pas à chaque fois il ya une
clés d'explication qui est la même pour
toutes ces réformes c'est qu'elles le
font sortir du en même temps le rapport
cap 22 sur les économies on ne dissimule
pas ce que ça nous place à droite mais
le plan pauvreté on ne fait pas parce
que ça nous place à gauche les lois
bioéthiques on les avait promis on
devrait le faire mais les conservateurs
qui nous soutiennent qu'est ce qu'ils
aiment bien la politique donc et puis
sur l'islam est ce qu'on est du côté des
républicains est ce qu'on est du côté
des communautaristes bon des
républicains je parle pas du parti mais
de là à ceci prés façon que les réformes
de la première année ont plutôt était
déjà classé à droite oui mais elle était
dans le programme
c'était des réformes du programme on
peut lui dire qu'elle était dans le
programme édit c'était je fais ce que je
dis et là il ya une emmanuel macron
alors on n'a pas le droit dans le monde
citer cette phrase dans les papiers
parce qu'elle est trop vécu les deux
phrases cardinal de retz on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment mais là
ont malheureusement des objets on est
obligé de la cité parce qu'il sait que
il en fait où il continue le en même
temps et à mon avis
il est condamné où il achève sa mue vers
la droite mais là il a sa majorité qui
risquent de grincer des dents
jean-luc dans l'ain je crois que c'est
très complexe je crois que je ne crois
pas du tout à la construction qui est
fait sur les deux jambes la jambe de
droite qui auraient été avancés
allègrement et la jambe de gauche
sociale qui ne l'a pas été je crois que
le bilan est extrêmement équilibrée
entre l'économie et la société mois soit
un vrai libéral libéral dans tous les
sens du terme politiquement notamment je
suis un disciple de tocqueville bon eh
bien je trouve que économiquement on les
réformes sont très prudentes sur le plan
du libéralisme
je suis également attaché au social je
vois qu on a fait plein de choses
notamment la politique du ministre de
l'éducation nationale
elle prend alors elle à bras le corps le
problème numéro un de la société
française avec la le vivier intégration
d'un certain nombre de gens qui sont en
marge et pas en faisant des réformes ou
des lois mais en faisant jour après jour
des changements des modifications des
adaptations de l'appareil éducatif ça
cela dit le discours officiel n'est pas
cela le discours officiel c'est le vôtre
le discours repas de gauguin à m'en
excuser moi c'est ce que vous venez de
dire
la seul exemple dédoublement du cpc le
soleil qui nous est donné le nom devient
non la taxe d'habitation était bon peu
on peut et on peut énumérer la lampe à
énumérer tous tout cela se serait sauvé
mais si la suppression des cotisations
sociales la la la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
mais peu importe c'est pas il ya plein
de choses mais l'un s'est pas là le
problème le problème à mon avis et là je
suis sensible à l'hésitation c'est que
c'est comme on dit dans le feuilleton
winter is coming en été mais winter is
coming en été c'est que la vie est dure
c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que les grands
engagements du président de la
république ce que j'approuve par exemple
engagements européens
eh bien ça se heurtent à d'énormes
difficultés que l'engagement économique
ce n'est pas vrai que il suffit de
prendre quelques mesures positives en
matière du marché de l'emploi pour
introduire une une croissance durable
les dépenses publiques on a bien vu à
quel point le gouvernement se heurte à
des difficultés et codé qu'il essaie de
faire quelque chose
il a des réactions négatives donc le
grand problème de l'élection l'année
dernière c'est qu'on a donné moi j'ai
pas fait ça quand je me suis présenté
mais personne n'a écouté ce que j'ai dit
dans ma circonscription
mais c'est le grand problème c'est qu'on
a donné le sentiment qu'il suffisait
d'un peu d'un vent de confiance d'un peu
d'espoir d'un président nouveaux jeunes
brillants et la de ce point de vue là la
comparaison avec hollande pour que tout
reparte et bien non les français sont en
train de découvrir qu'il faut agir très
en profondeur que ça va pas être amusant
et ils en veulent un peu à emmanuel
macron de leur avoir donné l'impression
inverse
laurent bouvet ça explique ce chiffre
notamment aussi de dons qu'on parlait de
l'efficacité mais aussi de la justice
trouvez vous que la politique menée par
emmanuel macron est juste et bien c'est
non à 71% ce jeu je fais suivre voilà
quand tu aller dans la rue juste là où
s'est arrêté
jean le blanc change avec lequel dans la
dernière partie je suis tout à fait
d'accord
on assiste aujourd'hui à du point de vue
des politiques publiques du point de vue
des politiques qui sont menées les
politiques économiques et sociales les
différentes réformes comme on dit qu'ils
ont été menés on est au moment où elles
ont beaucoup d'entre elles ont été
faites sans qu'il y ait des effets
encore est-ce qu'il y en aura ou pas je
ne me prononce pas là dessus je ne je ne
juge pas de savoir si ce sont de bonnes
réformes une mauvaise réforme est ce que
mais simplement il ya un effet quand
vous mettez des politiques publiques en
place on l'a dit tout à l'heure pour les
politiques de la ville
ce n'est pas immédiat on n'appuie pas
sur un bouton et ça ne se voit pas sauf
dans des cas très particuliers
le dédoublement des classes de cp par
exemple pour l'éducation nationale où là
on peut mesurer sur une classe sur un an
les effets ce qui a été fait et ça a
plutôt bien marché illicite mais c'est
très rare
les politiques publiques ce sont des
effets de long terme donc on est un
moment où ce qui l'a mis en oeuvre bon
mal bien ou pas ce qui n'a pas encore
mis en oeuvre etc on est dans
l'incertitude et c'est ce que ce qu'a
dit jean louis bourlanges ans juste
après également vincent d'êtres humains
qui s'applique c'est à dire que on
rentre dans le dur ces winter is coming
si on rentre dans le dur on rentre dans
les matières où il n'y a plus moi je
veux dire un peu autrement deux en même
temps possible sur 90% des sujets vous
pouvez faire du en même temps vous
pouvez rassembler des gens à condition
qu'ils soient de bonne foi de gauche de
droite sur des enjeux ça peut être au
cas par cas ça peut être sur des
programmes plus généraux et puis vous
faites ce qui s'est passé avec la
république en marche vous faites des
éléments vous mettez effectivement
réforme de la taxe d'habitation et
réforme de liesse f
vous faites lui en même temps simplement
il ya 10% des sujets et les sujets c'est
immigration-intégration identité
aujourd'hui donc l'islam de france la
laïcité la question des frontières la
manière dont on continue ou pas l'europe
et c'est avec ce qui se passe ce qui se
passe en ce moment mais aussi les
questions de fin de vie les questions de
pma les questions d'identité collective
de ce type là il n'y a pas deux en même
temps là vous devez choix et lille un
problème fondamental dans la présence d'
emmanuel macron cas prime structurel
depuis le début ça c'est pas au bout
d'un an qu'on s'en aperçoit certains
d'entre nous l'ont dit depuis le début
c'est que la campagne ne s'est pas fait
sur les enjeux il n'y a pas deux en même
temps parce que le président dans son
intelligence politique a bien compris
que s'il voulait être élu dans des
conditions même si elle est
exceptionnelle une configuration
exceptionnelle pour lui était que malgré
tout difficile 24% de socle au premier
tour eh bien il fallait surtout pas
mettre en évidence dans sa campagne ces
enjeux où il n'y a pas deux en même
temps possible parce que forcément il se
séparer d'une partie de l'électorat
donc aujourd'hui ça lui revient et ça
nous revient à tous et vous avez tout à
fait raison et ça lui revient à lui
puisqu'il a personnalisé alex est là
aussi pour pouvoir gagner pour pouvoir
sortir de la masse et il a personnalisé
à l'essai sur lie l'asie revient à vélo
ça lui revient à lui c'est comme l'a dit
jean louis bourlanges par la situation
européenne c'est à dire que les dix
façons de sujets dont vous parliez en
disant qu'il ya pas deux en même temps
ils sont imposés par l'actualité
européenne et j'irai même plus loin si
on en croit les travaux de domique
et qui moi m'ont convaincu dans son
ouvrage couvre à la démocratie c'est
c'est 10 % c'est-à-dire identité
immigration islam c'est le premier motif
de vote des peuples européens
aujourd'hui est donc un moment que j'y
mettrai dans mon travail tels que ce
soit économique et social mais bien là
lui il s'est passé pas les comportements
pouvoir imposer une fesse bonnes espèces
de contre ordre en voilà ans pour les
dimensions et les enjeux sociaux et en
disant est aidé dans mon avis sélection
italienne en bus qu'elle est bonne je ne
vais leur gré qui arrive fort que cela
je vais être plus fort que cela est à
partir de la france je vais vous montrer
on peut faire autre chose en europe et
notamment à partir un peu d'une illusion
économique cite c'est à dire où c'est
tous ces sujets d'identité de frontières
etc étaient finalement se résoudre est
parce que il n'ya pas de soldes et de
changer il y avait en qu'il serait chez
lui un partage géographique c'est à dire
il y avait l'europe de l'est et les
démocraties libérales et il y avait
l'europe de l'ouest avec des démocraties
libérales et l'italien ça et elle est
libérale ou libérale on en projet auquel
vous teniez tout ce dont tu me proposes
de l'aborder c'est la transition
effectivement la sphère elle agite le
quai d'orsay belle est aussi
intéressante sur le fond le figaro il
revient d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
longuement sous la plume de laure
mandeville la sphère la voici en
quelques mots c'est celle de cet
ambassadeur de france hongrie qui vient
d'être recadrées après la divulgation
d'un ces télégrammes diplomatiques
on pourrait lui il se fait aux voix ses
propos il se fait l'avocat du premier
ministre viktor orban notamment sur les
questions d'immigration
cette note aurait dû rester secrète
elles ne reflètent pas la position de la
france sur le sujet ont réagi les
autorités on regarde sur ce point
emmanuel macron c'était vendredi dernier
au sommet de bruxelles le jeu non
coopératifs et nationaliste non
seulement n'est pas digne de ce qui a
fait l'europe notre europe est née des
errements des derniers conflits mondiaux
mais il est en plus profondément
inefficace compte tenu de la réalité de
ces phénomènes migratoires
donc je désapprouve en tous points les
citations que vous ne venez de faire en
tout point elles ne correspondent
absolument à rien la position française
il s'agit maintenant d'une note dans la
nature est confidentiel et ce n'est pas
l'expression de la position officielle
française
cet ambassadeur aurait-il tenus
publiquement ses propos il aurait été
révoquée sur le champ sur la forme le
l'ambassadeur n'a pas le droit de dire
ce qu'il pense on veut voir quelle tête
le quai d'orsay c'est je crois que la
cia il ya vraiment un télescopage de
deux choses
il ya d'une part le la position sur le
fond
or monsieur le président de la
république dit clairement qu'il est en
désaccord avec l'ambassadeur mais il dit
aussi que celui-ci il implicitement
faisait parfaitement son travail en
donnant à sa hiérarchie son opinion son
analyse le problème cela s'est il rendu
public
ça a été rendu public et ça c'est pas de
la faux et il dit très bien qu'il ne l'a
pas qui est qui qui ne l'a pas révoqué
et là je crois qu'il ya vraiment alors
quelque chose que je connais bien parce
que je sais je vois très bien qui est la
personnalité qui va être nommé qui est
nommé ambassadeur hongrie à la place de
l'ambassadeur actuel c'est une personne
qui a été nommé il ya trois semaines au
d'un mois en conseil des ministres il
n'y a absolument aucune censure je fais
parce que c'est une amie à moi et
qu'elle fait actuellement sept heures
hongrois par jour
depuis trois semaines il ya eu
coïncidence entre ce changement
d'affectation et le et cette déclaration
donc ça a été très très difficile à
gérer sur le plan de la communication
par le gouvernement mais je trouve que
emmanuel macron est parfaitement dans
son dans son rôle est d'ailleurs le quai
d'orsay
c'est à peu près la position qui était
la sienne c'est nos agents en poste font
des analyses pour le gouvernement
librement en revanche ils n'ont pas
exprimé publiquement ce que n'a pas
préférant l'ambassadeur une position
différente de celle de la france donc
c'est vraiment une très grand malentendu
derrière tout cela mais derrière tout ça
il ya aussi problème de fond et je suis
moi je suis d'accord avec avec emmanuel
pas au delà de l'immigration etc
il se passe à l'est de l'europe quelque
chose de très grave
nous avons accueilli et j'ai été très
favorable s'est élargie semant des pays
qui ont souscrit un pacte d'adhésion aux
valeurs démocratiques et libérales je ne
crois pas qu'il puisse y avoir de
démocratie libérale
je crois que ce qui se passe en hongrie
et en pologne est actuellement très
préoccupant est que c'est peut-être le
plus grand défi que nous avons que nous
rencontrons dans la construction
européenne karine michel
sur le fond les propos de l'ambassadeur
pour les résultats quelle caricature un
peu c'est à dire hors ban le premier
ministre hongrois a eu raison avant tout
le monde sur les migrants c'est pas
nouveau en fête
sarah halifa legrand qui travaille chez
nos services étrangers l'avait rencontré
en 2015 et dès 2015 il tenait ce genre
de propos donc en effet il a le droit
d'avoir des positions et c'est même son
rôle d'avoir des positions reflétant
l'environnement où il est d'apporter
quelque chose d'autre à paris là où ça
prend un tel écho ici c'est que les
réactions des uns et des autres montre à
quel point on est entrée dans une
profonde incompréhension de ce qui se
passe dans les pays de l'est c'est à
dire que les responsables européens ne
comprennent pas ou ne veulent pas
comprendre qu' un certain nombre de
données de ces pays là qui sont passés
d'une domination soviétique à ce qu'ils
vivent comme une domination européenne
ils ont cru adhérer à quelque chose mais
finalement cela ne leur convient
peut-être pas totalement
c'est pas une maison de force alors
j'avais fini mais si si comment dire si
nous voulons collectivement donner un
sens à l'europe commencé en leur disant
si vous n'êtes pas content vous n'avez
qu'à partir ça sedan mon point de vue ça
n'est pas la meilleure s'il veut
renoncer au pacte que vous avez cités
qui agit aujourd'hui l'europe de l'est
comme vous l'avez dit très juste comment
très justement commence à agiter
l'europe du sud à dire que ce sera
certainement dans deux points qui sont
soulevées par ces pays là dans leur
contexte historique particulier qu'ils
ont été coupés pendant 50 ans de l'ouest
des migrations que bon un certain nombre
de chocs domination ottomane choisir ne
pas refaire un cours d'histoire mais ça
vient nous interroger sur un ca
un nombre de questionnements et
aujourd'hui à part faire l'autruche ou
leur dire le partij accompagné d'un
colloque au niveau 20 ans j'étais magog
étaient banque du comité mixte parlement
européen d'y être de pologne gelé
président et à la fin j'ai vu j'ai
accompagné la pologne avec des des gens
formidables mazowiecki geremek
valaisanne
c'était fantastique aujourd'hui adam
michnik héros martyrisé par le le
pouvoir le pouvoir communiste
on asphyxie son journal on asphyxie la
publicité on l'empêchent d'être livre le
la cour de justice agit en pologne c'est
extrêmement grave
ce sont des problèmes de fait on doit
réagir s'il s'agit pas d'écrire un petit
jeu des familles à la retraite
on a mis non mais c'est des choses très
amoureux en emea retraite le la moitié
du conseil quoi du conseil la cour
suprême et c'est ça veut dire que ce
sont des gens qui jugent les élections
demain on aura des élections européennes
si nous ne sommes pas contents de la
façon ça se passe c'est très grave parce
qu'on peut on peut avoir
l'ambassadeur il a il peut avoir comme
citoyens vivant connaissance et pays son
opinion il a il est légitime à le faire
simplement il est ambassadeur de france
dont il n'a pas à la donner il fait des
analyses publiquement mais quand il
parle à des journalistes ben il fait des
analyses pour le quai d'orsay et ça
l'analyse qu'il a fait est très
intéressante sur le fait de ne pas
continuer à considérer le cas au rhb
année le cas de ces cette évolution des
pays du triangle devise gradés
maintenant un peu au delà simplement de
la manière en leur disant écoutez ce que
vous faites c'est pas bien et c'est de
d'avoir un jugement d'une certaine
manière morale et de faire davantage de
politique donc là jusque là c'est très
bien sur le fond il ya un lien il ya un
double problème
d'abord ce que dit cet ambassadeur est
très intéressant effectivement je crois
qu'on juge et on fait beaucoup trop de
morale à la place de la politique et en
matière de politique étrangère c'est
encore pire quand ça tient de politique
intérieure si je puis dire si ça peut
être pire
or
il faut les écouter les discours dorman
de viktor orban chaque année quand les
pays du triangle devise grade se
réunissent dans les différents pays où
ils sont alternativement ils se
réunissent une sorte de conférence
il rame vide n'y fait il fait des
discours très intéressant parce que
c'est aussi une sorte de théoriciens or
ban
c'est c'est quelqu'un de très
intéressant et je pense qu'il faudrait
davantage les lire ici et une dernière
chose et l'autre partie je vais très
vite c'est que ça déborde maintenant des
pays de l'est et du centre de l'europe
l'italie bien sûr ça a été cité mais les
pays les pays scandinaves le parti
social démocrate danois vient d'adopter
une un programme une sorte de manifeste
de en renversant à 180 degrés sa
doctrine comme c'était le cas auparavant
au suédois avant ses terres d'accueil
etc en dix ans maintenant si on veut pas
les suédois uniquement les d'anouar mais
contrairement au suédois qui continuent
d'accueillir les étrangers star dans une
doctrine classique et bien les danois
disent le parti social-démocrate la
gauche danoise de gouvernement dit nous
ne pouvons pas continuer à accueillir
des immigrés si nous voulons préserver
notre modèle social donc c'est par
exemple les plus de rallyes aura le
dernier mot sur la question des
démocraties simplement simplement chacun
son tour s'il vous plaît je pense que si
la seule le les seuls mots vis-à-vis de
la hongrie de ces pays et de l'italie
c'est un disque disqualification morale
et la déligitimation politique et c'est
trop souvent le cas ces démocraties
libérales elles verseront elles
gagneront partout parce que dans cette
affaire fourni ce qui est intéressant
c'est de savoir s'ils devaient faire ou
pas faire mais l'idée que l'on puisse
nuancé le regard occidental sur or ban
n'apparaît pas comme intellectuellement
pertinente mais pourquoi pourquoi
n'est-il pas possible de se dire qu'est
ce qui explique que ces pays choisissent
des gouvernants comme ça et peut-être
qu'il faudrait qu'on se disent aussi que
les populations des opinions publiques
ces pays regarde notre modèle en disant
votre modèle a échoué votre vous
vous avez voulu nous donner un modèle et
il est joué allons regarder la pologne à
côté de l'ukraine
ce qu'on a fait en pologne depuis 20 ans
mon plus viktor orban moi j'étais un
fanatique des victoires en vannes dans
les années chaotiques de l'union de la
pologne a fait tout simplement je vais
pas notre cas je les jetais simplement
si on fait les ouvertures garder les
méchants les machos il y aura peut-être
pas les méchants et les gentils
ce sont je suis désolé c'est une
question de principe démocratique
on a adhéré ils ont adhéré librement à
un pacte qui comportait le respect d'un
certain nombre de principes auxquels on
doit être fondamentalement attaché non
nasride autres principaux mario draghi
vital
on n'a rien su de l'idéologie que je
désirais que le libéralisme
la démocratie est le capitalisme soit
intimement liée pour toujours est une
idée d'abord historiquement assez
récente et ce n'est pas une philosophie
disons substantielle c'est celle de
l'union européenne
mais ce n'est pas une philosophie d une
substance vl a établi dans des droits
fondamentaux des racines chrétiennes
quand il les revendique ils disent dans
la construction européenne elle y était
et donc en quoi ils ne sont pas et ils
résident à sa sauce descente de
fonctionnalités racines chrétiennes de
l'europe je veux dire c'est que même une
philosophie de l'europe qu'ils n'ont pas
et cette philosophie et les pays bric
mais pas levé tout à fait kruth la
charte des droits fondamentaux
mais c'est tout mais cocteau sur quoi
croyez-vous qu'on a fondé l'europe
depuis 1950 sur le refus du stalinisme
sur le refus du frontis sur l'europe et
ils ont rejoint le roi dont il était
très heureux de rejoindre l'europe
moi je me suis engagé un long mais
d'accord je suis entièrement d'accord
avec l'élargissement je combats de plus
20 ans l'idée qu'on a eu on a un cocon
devait accepter ces pays et les aider à
progresser
fondée et le résultat en pologne et
familiale ce que je donne mes pas ces
deux choses c'est qu'on déchire g
principe sur lequel cette adhésion s'est
faite et qu'on dise que l'europe
ressemble à une nouvelle forme d'union
soviétique qui serait une maison de
force
non l'europe et en une maison lee
depuis le traité de lisbonne si on veut
en sortir les anglais le monte on en
sort si on veut y rester
on ne respecte les principes
fondamentaux quand on a signé un contrat
on respecte le contrat ou montrond
contrat mais on ne fait pas les deux
choses à la fois on ne dit pas je veux
l'argent massif de l'union européenne
est en revanche vos principes les
principes auxquels j'ai adhéré
je n'en veux pas il ya un problème qui
est beaucoup plus grave et plus je
compte vous demande une femme je te dis
pas je ne vais pas fait comme il veut
mais je veux que la démocratie soit
maintenant oui je n'ai non c'est pas
moral mais laurent explique jean michel
aguirre de cette émission alors je suis
votre existence est plus agressive et si
on discute pas mais vous avez raison à
laquelle peuvent vous avez raison d'être
passionnés et de l'exprimer ainsi mais
malheureusement les règles du jeu c'est
que l'émission est terminée on n'aura
même pas le temps mais ça serait ça sera
pour une autre fois aussi de parler foot
cyclisme pas de pas de point de vue
demain pour cause de match de foot mais
vous suivrez tout ça sur figaro live
merci beaucoup beaucoup à tous les
quatre et rendez vous lundi pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]